thousands are at the u.s border wearing
joe biden
t-shirts begging the u.s president to
let them in
they are among millions currently headed
for the same border
[Applause]
[Music]
joe biden doesn't see a crisis brewing
his whole plan to deal with the border
issue boils down to hope
and a prayer did you receive a briefing
about the border today
yes i did what did you learn a lot
is there a crisis
[Applause]
[Music]
his administration doesn't see a problem
either just a challenge and they're
ready to welcome more migrants
do you believe that right now there's a
crisis at the border
i think that the the answer is no
i think there is a challenge at the
border that we are managing
and we have our resources dedicated to
to managing it
we are not saying don't come we are
saying don't come
now because we will be able to deliver
um a safe and orderly process to them
as quickly as possible biden moved to
undo the trump administration's
migration policies
one of the first moves was to set up a
juvenile detention facility
but he insists this is not kids in cages
as trump did
the migrant crisis spawns a lot of crime
in just three days
1 600 migrants were arrested with
criminals reportedly among them
and criminal organizations have
certainly flourished among communities
that are afraid to call the police out
of fear of deportation
there are people coming across a large
number that are criminals
a lot of people just looking for a
better way of life unfortunately
it could create a situation where they
may be vulnerable
to criminal organizations trying to
abuse them critics say the white house
is just not being realistic about the
potential dangers
of its policy the green light is is on
now
we're open for business again and it is
the worst message to be sending to the
traffickers
who are smuggling these kids across the
border polls show that trump's border
wall remains very popular despite that
congress is moving forward on what the
democrats call sweeping immigration
legislation
presenting an eight-year path to
citizenship for 11 million people in the
country without papers
such an amnesty would be adding a new
layer of u.s citizenship
roughly the size of california the whole
process
allows people to come in without
providing for them
the shelter the opportunity the jobs
is gonna be a major task to handle
and i don't think the government the u.s
government
is ready and capable to handle
all of these illegal immigration that
state
already a lot of them in deficit due to
that pandemic
hit us and a lot of business has been
closed
millions of people are out of work and
now to add
a legal the crowds at the border are
getting larger and the country is
becoming more polarized while trump may
be gone
the immigration debate is getting more
intense it's becoming the most
polarizing issue
in a country that is already quite
divided caleb maupin
rt new york